hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game from the French team
championship it's from round two and uh
it's a game between uh a Spanish
Grandmaster Alvar Alonso Russell and a
French Grandmaster Jonathan durera so I
have no idea if that is how you
pronounce it but let's go with that and
the game comes as a suggestion from
David Lada himself so if you've seen
some of the games that he suggested in
the past that I've covered in the
channel you know that you are in for a
beautiful bloodbath now let's check it
out and also one of the things I
discovered while preparing this game
okay you always discover some things
while analyzing a game but here there is
one uh moment in the game where game
could have taken a completely different
turn and it could have been a a entirely
different game but we are only going to
discuss that after I show you what
actually happened in the game so let's
check it out all that Alonso Russell
with the white pieces opens with D4 we
have d5c4 going for the Queen's Gambit
and E6 declining the Gambit with 9 to
have three Knights to F6 and now G3
going for the Catalan opening Bishop to
E7 and now Bishop to G2 so this is all
very standard stuff nothing new
Happening Here we have castles Queen to
C2 and now usually here you will see C6
or something like C5 or even D captures
and C4 but Knight the C6 is a very very
rare move and you don't see it very
often because it blocks Black's C pawn
and that's something you don't want to
do something Philadelphia taught us many
many years ago so here uh A3 uh grabbing
hold of the B4 squirrel so you want to
advance the pawn to B4 at some point D
captures and C for Queen captures and C4
and now just Queen to D5 offering a
queen trade now this is possible you
don't have to worry about any
discoveries as the White Queen on C4 is
attacked so just Knight V to D2
defending the queen and the black plays
Rook 38 and none of them uh I want to
just capture and improve the position of
the other player's pieces with E3 and
now comes Queen to H5 and with this
queen to H5 move it is now as of move 10
that we have a completely new game we
have H3 and now Bishop to D6 it's hard
uh to decide how to develop the pieces
with black here we still have to put the
bishop somewhere and you want to get
your Rooks into the game so you have to
figure out how to go about that here we
have Bishop to D6 sort of uh moving the
the same piece twice but black has an
idea here and now comes Bishop
sorry Queen back to E2 here white could
have uh played E4 E4 is a very nice move
that threatens E5 and it would really uh
Force the black to figure out what he
wants to do probably something like
Knight to D7 back to B6 attacks the
queen and so on uh but okay here we have
Queen back to E2 and now comes Bishop to
D7 black also could play a very nice
breakthrough with Ponte E5 pretty much
solves all of Black's problems if D
captures Knight captures for example
Knight captures Queen captures Black's
position is now uh well sort of perfect
but okay Bishop to D7 was played in the
game with e for now threatening E5 and
the bishop to f8 not allowing the double
double attack we have Castles by white
and here uh Queen back to A5 now
stopping B4 if you play B4 Knight
captures on B4 you still haven't
connected your Rooks and also your uh
Queen day four is coming Knight to A5
and the Knight wants to come to B3 so
here we have Rook to D1 and now uh Queen
to A4 as planned with Ponte E5 Knight to
D5 and now Knight the E4 so putting a
lot of uh Knights here in front of the
black king Knight the A5 black continues
to play on the queen side and now comes
knight uh F to G5 yeah preparing Queen
to H5 and here black really has to
figure out how to defend this position
this is not an easy position to defend
uh in fact it's uh it's an incredibly
difficult position to defend and in the
game uh Ponte H6 was played uh there are
other maybe options which we are going
to discuss after we check out the game
but feel free to pause the video now and
try to find the absolute best move for
white while I give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
incredible attacking idea and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is night captures on F7 now you have
to capture otherwise you've just
blundered upon and uh well white is all
over the place so King captures an F7
and now Bishop captures an H6
sacrificing another piece and here best
course of action for black is to
actually accepted this but it's not an
easy thing to do for example if captures
Queen to H5 with check and look at this
King to E7 and now Knight to C5 attacks
the queen uh very few squares left for
that Queen let's say queen to C6 you can
put the Rook on C1 and now I mean look
at it look at the the position of the
king the position of the queen this is
just uh terrible that maybe even if
black can't survive this somehow most
certainly not in a in a practical game
so after Bishop captures an H6 black
said all right we're not gonna play that
Bishop to E8 attempted by Jonathan and
now comes the bishop to G5 also very
cool idea is Knight to G5 with check and
now after King the E7 look at this queen
to E4 and black just resigns there is no
move black in play here uh it's just
um well it's just completely unplayable
if if you accept the bishop then you
allow Queen to H7 Queen to H7 check now
you give up the two Bishops and it's
Checkmate there's no way to defend that
uh other than that after Queen T4 maybe
you you try to escape with King to D7
but um
uh sorry with King to D7 uh but even
that will not be be great Queen to G4
can come and again there's no good way
to defend this so okay in the game after
Bishop T8 Queen uh Bishop to G5 was
played uh not allowing G captures on H6
which is also perfectly fine for white
attacking The Rook on d8 and now comes
King to G8 the black finds some safety
for the king Bishop capture 78 Rook
captures and now Pawn to B4 we have
knighted to B3 and now Rook a to B1 with
Knight captures on D4 uh if you don't if
you don't trade this there is really no
good uh well there there's really no
good way to to play this with black so
here are Knight captures on D4 Rook
captures on D4 and now Knight to F4
going for a little trick here attacking
the queen and the undefended Rook on D4
but luckily white has this beautiful
Knight the F6 with check which opens up
the G file and allows a queen to for
with check so G captures on F6 Queen to
G4 with check Knight to G6 now the queen
also defends the Rogue but it doesn't
matter Rook capture 78 and now after F5
attacking the queen queen to G5 still
not allowing the Knight to move King to
H7 and now the beautiful B5 absolutely
spectacular and now the queen no longer
defends the bishop and if you move the
bishop your Bishop on f8 is no longer
defended well okay it is by the Knight
but it's not gonna do all that all that
much good because look at this bishop
captures on B5 now comes Rook captures
an f8 uh sacrificing The Exchange but it
only appears that way Knight captures an
f8 and now Rook the B for a beautiful
attack attacking the queen and
threatening mate in one with Rook to H4
so you have to play Queen to D1 check
King to H2 and now the only way to uh
the the to guard the H4 Square to
prevent Checkmate is the plane Knights
the G6 but that also means your Bishop
on B5 is left unguarded and even though
we even with the bishop here your
position is uh completely winning with
white now after capturing the bishop you
are simply up a full rook and of course
this is instant resigns by
uh by Jonathan Durer saw here uh giving
uh Alvar Alonso Russell a spectacular
victory in round two of the French team
championship so really a wild attack
that happened pretty much out of nowhere
after Queen to H5 completely new move uh
yeah like I said it was it wasn't easy
to develop this game with black then
black started to bring over the pieces
to the queen side and white just took
this opportunity and started sacrificing
but remember when I said that we are
going to repeat this and let's say
Knight to G5 and here that black played
H6 there is another move that black can
play here if you guys are interested
feel free to pause the video and try to
find an even stronger move for black
than H6 while I give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
very very uh weird idea and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is Bishop to E8 if you found this move
then uh you truly should not be watching
my videos as you are too strong a chess
player uh so you know big
congratulations on that uh but uh the
the understand why Bishop T8 is so
strong we first have to ask ourselves uh
how is black preventing Checkmate look
at this Knight captures on H7 King
captures Queen to H5 with check King to
G8 and not Knight to G5 how are we to
stop checkmate with black well the point
is there's Queen to C2 stopping Queen H7
Checkmate and it doesn't seem like it's
all that impressive Bishop E4 attacks
the queen and again we just Checkmate
the black king sorry about the weird
Arrow the problem is uh White already
sacrificed one piece for the attack and
now with Bishop to E4 which is the only
move uh for white uh black just plays
Queen captures on e4 now you've grabbed
two pieces for the queen and you're not
stopping there look at this Knight
captures an E4 Pawn to F5 and now you
see the real reason of Bishop to E8 this
uh this uh double attack and the
grabbing of the third piece is the real
idea or the the real reason why we play
Bishop T8 now the queen has to move
Queen to H4 and now let's F captures an
E4 Queen captures and now just Knight to
B3 uh a couple of very simple moves to
let's say continue the game You're Gonna
Play A5 and whatever white plays You're
Gonna Play A4 now look at this position
uh uh yes you are down a queen but you
have a knight a knight and a light
Square Bishop for the queen so that's
compensation in itself another thing you
have a knight on B3 which is a light
Square white can never touch this Knight
another Knight on D5 also a lights where
beautifully protected Outpost uh again
uh White cannot attach this you have the
bishop pair and you have the two Rooks
blacks only weakness in the position uh
is the is the uh 6 Pawn which can easily
be defended and okay you have to be a
little bit worried about maybe the pawns
marching forward but you have so many
pieces to go after the white king as
well so this is uh for example where
things could have taken a completely
different turn if uh black for example
in this position win for this bishop T8
idea it's a it's a I mean no one finds
this move it's an incredibly difficult
move to find and unless you are ready to
really go deep and find ways to to give
up your queen with Queen to see to Queen
captures and E4 then maybe you know if
if you really go go deep and far then
you will find a move like Bishop to E8
but uh after H6 which is even the second
strongest move recommended by the engine
uh White's attack just becomes too
strong and there was no bouncing back
after
uh uh after white just started
sacrificing everything uh and it was a
well a a fairly uh clean and quick
Victory especially this Rook to be for
moved very nicely done uh so yeah uh
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
once again uh thank you David Lada for
suggesting such a such a wonderful game
I hope you get many more in the future
from you I would like to thank ravishing
reptiles YouTube Andrew Nader uh Selena
Kashi Ben Benjamin and Brandon Cole for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of
everything else that's happening in the
Chess World and uh well just checking up
on your wonderful suggestions as they
are always full of uh really awesome
games so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day